hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2016 I'm your host Daniel
O'Dwyer delighted to be joined by mr.
Daniel Oh Horry Wella Howie well I die
alone good names join the cross also
peter brian is here i'm in the middle
yes you were here I mean we're delighted
to have you here Peter delighted have
you here Daniel we've also got a live
demo yes the new Legend of Zelda game
which has a title as well yes Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild which was
finally announced today we've been
trying to keep that under wraps for a
while and it's great it really does talk
about what the game is like were this
huge world you get to explore and it had
his own sense of its own sense of being
um and it's really just fun to kind of
wander around and see what you can
discover it's been wonderful seeing the
demo on obviously your Nintendo Direct
sage and streaming this morning I woke
up and watched a bunch of it it's been
fun fascinating to see how open you were
being with this you're showing up a lot
of this game yes ya know it's been off a
lot of the game and it's just one area
and mr. new even talked about this
before that it essentially only
represents this demo like less than two
percent right of the full game if Sara
wants to put up chance you bring up the
map for a second just give you an idea
of scale um sick I got ya she now uses
NFC yeah yeah there's a little thing
over there so that this is one little
section of the map you get to explore
and it's huge um so be a lot of stuff
there are people to discover when they
have their chance but what Sarah's doing
right now actually we're starting in
this little camping here at he began she
collected some items but she's actually
doing some cooking so before link goes
on his adventure he's gonna get prepared
um to survive as best as possible um so
you have you collect certain items like
meats vegetables insects and monster
parts too and you can mix them together
to make different things um there no
hearts in the game anymore like you
could cut grass and get hearts right
yeah that's going on okay you don't have
to worry about foraging constantly and
then you can eat them raw to give you
some a health fact but you can cook them
together to create more different things
instead like this right here this hearty
meat and mushroom skewer it gives you
full recovery but also gives you an
extra heart the bonus heart on that's
yellow which doesn't mean it can be
refilled but it gives you that extra
extra help until you get hit and lose it
you talk about removing the hearts and
for me that is removing a layer of
abstraction getting experience that link
is going through but at the same time
there is so much charm to the way in
which he's I mean I hate to say it
killing innocent animal but he's
gathering a steak from it right and then
when I look at all the food is bouncing
around he's got in his mouth like his
all heads I think it's just really
wonderful how you maintain the spirit of
Zelda games while also fundamentally
changing the traditional elements of it
yes and that's something that are really
trying to go for this title is make it
be feel something completely different
you've ever seen before even if you
shoot a bird it turns into like a nice
little piece of me or shoot a squirrel
turns you an acorn it's going on the
game so are you doing a lot of that
cooking to prepare for battle or to use
during battle because I gotta hit like
it was your liking it before actress
right now here she's going to this book
of land encampment and you see the boar
actually is running around distracting
the guy on the become oh yeah and
Sarah's down here fighting this other
book hablen hope she was fighting with
her torch which applies in the best
weapon to use so she's actually dodging
around and you can jump in the game now
as well right which is a nice change and
then they get to be careful to is that
your weapons as you use them and the
shield they'll take damage the
durability matter so you're in the
constantly looking for new weapons and
it really encourage you to keep grabbing
different things now one thing I'm
really curious about when it comes to
durability because I got some time to
play the game on Sunday and you get this
feeling that these items are very
disposable yeah you know in the past
you'd get an item you're like this is
very important to me and that would
almost define who link was right so I
understand the master sword is back in
the game I saw a little glimpse of it
over the weekend we don't know what that
is exactly ever you can make that is so
the sword that I saw seems to be a
object that has some amount of
permanence to it but for the most part
is all of your equipment is it
disposable in the sense that it might
not be permanent or you do find items
that really do stick with you the entire
trip or what we're showing so far is
there the dirt they are kind of
disposable for right now the games still
be in the works and we're only showing a
small sample right now so stay tuned to
see what we'd share later on or not and
how do you add in all these mechanics
and still keep this you know an
accessible game because the Zelda games
have always been ones that like folks
who don't play big crazy open-world RPGs
could pick up and play yeah it's just
that's something the Tenno does that I'm
new has been great with that just in
town as a whole they're always making
sure that if you want if you want to be
if you want a het make the game really
complicated with some really crazy moves
you can do that if you don't you can
just enjoy the experience of going
through the game and the story as it is
so it's trying to make that charm for
everybody and their do a really good job
a bang but the control wise yeah it's it
guides you through pretty basically when
you first start the game that's specific
fsx yeah that's a more complicated move
to do as well um but she practices
practices and as you get through the
game it gives it all to in bite-sized
chunks so you never tries to throw you
the whole thing at one time so tonight's
way to simply gather and learn as you go
through it and what are the types of
sort of slide activities are there
they're cooking cooking some fishing and
hunting swimming yeah stuff like that um
yeah just just discovering so that's the
main activities are going through that
we've shown so far and here's I was
trying to take on this giant rock
monster that called the step tallest
that appeared and this is just randomly
appears that you're wandering around so
it's a figure out what's going on she
actually right there used one of what's
new to the game is the runes so ten
imagining a van a bomb item she had
these made his magical runes basically
that you can earn by completing the
shrines of trials there was over 100 of
them and here but she got thrown off so
here she's trying to find a way to
defeat this character which it actually
gives a lot of energy and right now
sheep I did not have enough to do it so
she might come back later with a more
powerful weapon could you saw a weak
point on its head right was what she's
able to get to bomb but she was able to
use a remote bomb to get it to fall over
to climb on its back is there going to
be an element of that like you see
another you know open-world role-playing
games where you're wandering into areas
which are clearly higher than your
abilities or are you getting these or
either like sort of enclosed open areas
that you're moving to level two level no
I mean from web experience so far it's
very reminiscent of the original zelda
game we're from the nes where you could
just explore and you go you can go there
you might go whoops I shouldn't be here
right now or you have the right of the
right room or right weapon or item to
get passed on if you might the market
and come back to it later on that's
really just to do that freedom you have
to go through this open adventure
open-air adventure and choose how you
want to explore everything what are the
ramifications if you do go into an area
that's too strong and you end up
you know dying like how does this game
is a pretty accommodating that kind of
experimentation and risk-taking yeah it
is pretty accommodating I mean you shot
from the demo that we showed on Sunday
Nate actually he died and he died right
yeah and then what makes even funnier it
leaves an X on the map showing where you
last died so it would be fun for that
one too but yeah I know it's been
successful you come right back um yeah
and that's what we're showing so far on
the demo right now so what does the edge
of the map look like cuz it's huge and
I'm sure can take a long time for people
to make all the way there but is it you
can look over everything and actually
what we're going through right now share
will eventually get over there right now
she's just trying to take out this
pokolbin encampment and show a really
cool move right here I'll chitra so
they're all goofing around she's just
throwing a remote bomb over there if
there are a hundred of these shrines is
it safe to assume that you know some of
them will offer maybe upgrades to
existing abilities that you've earned or
are there that many there the shrines of
trials on the ones at least in the demo
so for each of them do give you a
different room okay to earn right now we
already have two of them here which is
why she up good dodge there Sarah I is
the the remote bomb which is one of the
rooms and the other one she has is that
missus which is um you can actually grab
items that had magnetic properties and
move them around um the other two
shrines do other things as well but the
trial be different some are small sum
will be big some will have will be 0 and
right now we've only shown these for
that basically shows how to get those
runes um so we'll have to go into later
on we've learned more about what the
other shrines have to offer one thing
I've noticed is missing or rupees is
their currency in this game so far we
haven't you anything with the currency
yet um the game still being worked on so
yeah ever have to wait and see with that
I know be sure and we're talking about
too is that the world is a living
breathing world you will get to meet
other characters arm and that'll
probably lead into more of that
discovery later on so still being worked
on so hopefully we'll see what comes out
of that a lot of questions coming at a
chat remind people if they are watching
on gamespot com or on switch on keeping
an eye on both chats and one of the
questions this come in is a bad sort of
have populated the world is and how what
we're looking at here that there seems
to be lot of sort of empty space between
these encampments is that what you're
kind of looking at you you're spending a
lot of time on your own or is
is the world does it get more popular
it's a bigger stick townships and things
like that that we haven't shown you and
that's we're hoping I know it's a
question a lot of us are asking and the
games me worked on there there will be
stuff to discover beyond this and that's
the whole point that you don't know
what's going on is this gorgeous world
that has stuff going on but it's all in
a ruined state and you don't know what's
going on and that's what the player gets
to have the joy of discovering it's
finding out what that is and how you get
to discover that is gonna be different
cuz you can choose whatever path you
want to get there at the fire stuff I
mean I love far cry 2 so when I saw link
here setting fire to a bunch of grass
and unusally right here she also I oh my
goodness that I hit one tactical use of
fire blowing it goddamn self up so as
what she's doing there's actually some
book hablas in the back and she was
having now she's trying to brother she's
trying to burn the fire and you can't
actually get the fire to burn all the
way and take them out by burning them oh
right okay this one the fire didn't
quite British my pick him up by hand Oh
or she could distill relight her torch
she's determined to burn those dudes
alive okay almost yeah what are the uses
are there for the fire in the game of
cooking purposes as well so a lot of
time to get to the cooking areas you can
find a cooking pan to use beef like the
fire Nathan you all just find an open
fire and use that as well oh nice job
just hang up these guys and now she's
going to discover up the sword she has
is now currently badly damaged so what
she could try to do is throw up you
might take it out first she's trying to
throw the sword we got to control your
weapons look
can you speak a little bit about the
Amigo support I know Nintendo Tom
assassination earlier but I'd love to
hear a bit more oh yeah so right now the
only thing we've shown us about the
amoeba support of this game is the wolf
link amiibo um which if you do scan the
wolf link amiibo in wolf link will
actually join by your side and be a
partner for you to actually go fighting
and foraging for different hunting for
different things and what's cool that if
you play Twilight Princess HD and you've
built up that willfully move from the
extra content in the game the heart
you've earned will carry over into this
game so your wolf link will actually
have that many hearts in the game what's
cool is if that look link amiibo dies
while you're playing the wolf link dies
while you're playing you can't rescan
him back in until the next day the real
day like a real physical 24 hours right
okay so is the wolf link sold by itself
or can you only purchase it with toilet
right now you can only buy it with
Twilight Princess HD is that the plan
for the future as well we have nothing
to say right now the Oakland comes up in
the future right now yeah the wolf link
amiibo something you buy with Twilight
Princess HD which makes sense so you can
actually play up the game and then get
on play the game and get that extra
because he carries over the stats the
statutory of the hearts the heart
attacks carries over into this game as
well and I know just to clarify some of
the people in a child where the confused
because obviously we have a female game
demo or off camera yeah at link though
is a male male character yes there's no
option to pick a know right now link is
a male character right now in the game
that's how it's being prepared um that's
how the story works so far but yes our
friend Sarah on the side there she is
playing the game for us right now and
she has the five no she actually has the
fire out already and she's kind of been
using a little bit but what's cool here
she's about to do is the interaction
with the environment now we came from
the from the lower side but had she come
up from this side from another direction
she could have pushed these boulders
down and killed by the coffins that way
so that's something that's also really
fun about these Zelda games is that
there's always a sense of puzzle even
though their behalf of the shrines have
different puzzles but even even
defeating enemies there's always a
puzzle mechanic behind like how do you
what's the best way to defeat an enemy
or approach a different situation and
Peter was talking a lot about the
durability earlier on I mean crafting is
something that is almost ubiquitous
across the multiple genres especially
role-playing games in this stage is
there an also an element of that and in
the new cell there will you be like
finding recipes and and making things
and like trying things out
cooking is actually a really good part
we have a chance to do that which like
so if you mix meats and vegetables you
can make something together and then if
you make if you take monster parts which
you get from defeating enemies and
insects you can create elixirs right
lectures can give you different bonuses
like the ability to run faster have
longer stamina cold resistance things
along those lines here and now actually
write that there to the right is not
Helia and you know it's right now link
is getting cold easy in the bottom right
corner that gauge blinking I was gotten
so cold now that link is literally
shivering oh so you have to ops at this
point one you could put on this better
tunic you can take it all off as well
right you could take off you come in and
everything you'd be freezing that much
more um so yeah that's what she's doing
there but what we're doing here now with
link is link is using another room
called Magnus's which is the ability to
move objects that had metal properties
Wow and now she's now link right here is
building a bridge to use to get across
so presumably this will be a large part
of the puzzle solving in the temple
zamana yeah in the shrine strong through
the shrines are going through on you'll
be using that as well and that you
actually earned this ability by going
into one of the shrines of trials and
that's when you first experiment you
basically walk in you scan your Chico
slate which is what stores those power
those runes hours and then you can start
accessing those rooms to use that now
just confirm something I heard yesterday
this will be playable with the pro
controller correct correct mr. I numa
did say that the game will be compatible
with the pro controller as well um yeah
so that's the zest that's something i
know people be excited about as well
i've got a bunch more questions but
we're running short on time so peter i
want to sort of throw it to you because
you did play this game for about 40
minutes or you played me wait way many
or more of a zelda games than me do you
have any more questions for daniel sort
of a about what we've seen here I mean
there's so many things it's really
difficult to know I mean I suppose how
much what is the balance that's being
struck here between delivering a classic
Zelda experience like the original one
on the NES versus trying to modernize
this series I I'm curious about your
perspective on that as someone who
actually has played you said a little
bit hours they specific this Pacific
demo I played for about about 20 yeah
it's it's interesting how the balance
work so I mean and it's dinner for
everybody like I've played zelda games
in the past I know a lot of people have
never played a Zelda grant and this is a
great opportunity to jump in for the
very first time so it just depends on
each person everyone's different
gameplay experiences and memory like for
me it's nostalgia of my memories
remember playing many different Zelda
games that they've come up through the
years and is seeing how its evolved in
different stories how link go through
all these different adventures is just a
really fun way to play through the mall
is there any sort of multiplayer
component at all as of now we haven't
announced anything in that regard um
nothing i'm not that yeah i mean i
wouldn't even know how to begin to
imagine how that would work but this is
such an ambitious game that i have to at
least consider the possibility that if
you're gonna go one step in them to nap
so you might go the third as well have
to wait and see what's going i hope
we'll see what makes you come to as you
go down like down the path folks is
showing off a lot very early so
presumably there's a lot more to show
her home before yes i like it add daniel
orihuela thank you so much for coming on
in showing us the legend of zelda Breath
of Fire the Breathitt brother while
Brett of the wallet she would I know I
know we were using a lot of fires were
playing through the game now right
Brendan everything up it was that a bad
movie Breath of Fire that's an old RPG
series yeah that's it Jackson my money
thank you so much for a come on show
thank you when will it be out on Anwar
platforms so we have announced the game
come so the game comes out sometime in
2017 it'll be released simultaneously on
both the wii u and the NX we'd be on
that we haven't given any kind of
timeframe beyond next year when we hear
more about the annex Daniel the NFS yeah
we're all friends here nothing else to
share right on that one on the side that
it's coming out next year okay good to
have you here thank you so much thank
you I appreciate it you can check out
more of The Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild there you go Peter brand Thank
You president Zelda expert you can catch
more of that on Nintendo's stream that's
running across the rest of the week as
well make sure you stick around here
though we have got todd howard on to
talk about skyrim and a lot more we'll
be back in just a couple of minutes
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads